Question,
how is capitalism compatible with your
definition of good if it requires ever
increasing use of the finite resources
of the planet,
where once depleted would mean our end?
Well,
I would say capitalism isn't compatible
with my definition of good if it
requires every increasing uses of the
finite resources of the planet,
but that's by no means self evident even
though the Scuttlebutt,
let's say,
especially among the environmentalist
oriented types who might have some
sympathy for,
by the way,
especially with regards to ocean
depletion.
Um,
there's a huge argument and there has
been for many,
many years between the economists and
the biologists and this is a really
important thing to know.
And The economist point out that human
ingenuity is such that we're continually
able to make more with less.
And certainly over the last well,
500 years that the,
especially in the last 150 years,
that's just absolutely evident.
You know,
like people say we're going to run out
of energy.
And I think that's absolutely
preposterous.
It's like it's,
it's crazy as thinking we're going to
run out of mattered.
I mean,
we're going through a bit of a
bottleneck right now because you know
the population is going to increase to
about 9 billion and then it's going to
decrease.
That's,
that's the most reliable projections and
9 billion isn't the law more than we
have now and you know,
there's going to be some environmental
disruption as a consequence of that,
but I don't think there's any reason to
assume that all that capitalism
necessarily requires ever increasing use
of the finite resources of the planet.
It's also not obvious to what degree the
resources of the planet are actually
finite because we,
we can continually think up new uses for
things that nobody thought had any use
at all.
So it depends to some degree on whether
or not you're willing to bet on human
imaginativeness or you're going to be a
male Uzi and pessimist.
And I'm not saying that there are
reasons for both.
I'm just saying that it is by no means
self evident that things are getting
worse.
You know,
like I can give you an example.
So,
you know,
in the last,
in the last 15 years,
the millennium goal for the UN was to
have world poverty,
like absolute poverty,
so that's less than a dollar 50 a day by
50 percent within 15 years that was
actually reached ahead of schedule and
we've lifted hundreds of millions of
people into the middleclass over the
last 30 years.
And so there is an increasing inequality
in the west because the working classes
taken the brunt of that say that
redistribution to third world countries.
But by the same token,
you know,
there's no starvation in the world
anymore except really for reasons of
misdistribution and,
and,
and political purpose.
And people are becoming richer and more
educated all the time.
And you know,
when we are waking up to our planetary
responsibilities,
once people stopped starving to death
and having to burn like dirt and,
and eat,
you know,
substandard food that they've scraped
out into the Brown.
They do start to turn their attention to
things that might be more aesthetic.
And so look,
I don't think any reason to be
pessimistic,
not fundamental.
And I guess the reason that capitalism
is compatible with my definition of
good,
I wouldn't say that exactly.
I would say that I don't see an
alternative that has manifested itself
that doesn't have far more negative
consequences.
You know,
it's sort of a minimal pessimism issue.
It's like,
well this is the best devil that we have
and I do believe it is because the
successful societies,
by any stretch of the imagination,
by virtually any metric are the
capitalist societies.
It's certainly the case,
for example,
that the Soviet Union demolished far
more of its natural resources.
Too Far less a productive consequence
than the west did hearsay evidence.
There's suggestions that between 10 and
15 percent of the total area of the
Soviet Union has been rendered more or
less permanently uninhabitable.
So the question is,
compared to what.